so the question today today is what's
your biggest fear that's it for hiring
writers for hire spiders are you afraid
of spiders well good morning believe
nation today's message is get the right
people over to you chris bangle first
and foremost you want designers are
bringing energy to the table people who
come in there they're highly highly
motivated they have enormous amount of
creativity you can see it it bubbles out
of them they seem unstoppable the best
people in that sense that you have when
you're talking to them they look at you
like this hang on look I just wanna do
cars okay let's just do some cars those
are fantastic those are the race horses
you just want to turn them loose but if
that's all you have
maybe our missing some intellectual
depth you have to make sure you get the
deep thinkers in their their artistic
bent ones who who are sometimes shy
they're they're often intimidated by the
aggressiveness of the other type of
people but they are often the quiet
sleeper ones that come up with that deep
deep idea that you go let's develop
let's develop let's develop let's
develop so what do you think I think for
anyone who has experienced hiring people
they would say this is this is really
really obvious what's not obvious though
for maybe an earlier entrepreneur I know
myself is I screwed up every single
first hire that I ever did every role
that I created every first hire was like
I just wasn't managing them right I
didn't have properly defined roles or
expectations I wasn't looking for the
right people and it was just I just
messed it up I mess it up every time
because you're like you're and you're
hiring you're just like oh thank
goodness you're here to fix all of the
crap I don't want to deal with here you
go hopefully you can make it work and so
I mean his bigger point is you need
people who are passionate who love what
they're doing love coming into work who
if anything you're like almost holding
them back and you're like okay have at
it and then off they go and then you
also need those quiet thinkers who are
gonna deal with with the other stuff and
impress you and surprise you with what
they're doing you know that comes down
to culture that comes down to knowing
what you want having clearly defined
roles and having people work within you
know what do you say you hire for for
purpose or for culture not for talents
you can train up talents you know
looking back I think that's all obvious
to me today when I started I just like I
messed up hires like all the time so you
look at marks business now he's got a
million dollar plus business you've got
how many people on your team there are
nine of us nine people on the team for
me what I took from this is I would go
even earlier like I would look at the
startup entrepreneur and first suggests
a mindset of I need to do everything
myself cuz most entrepreneurs never even
grow to the point where they have a team
and it's recognizing that you can't do
everything yourself and that your real
growth will come by having people on
board to help you one for the skills and
the talents that you may not be good at
but two for the action motivation and
boost of having a team being responsible
for them and tackling a big mission I
think a lot of entrepreneurs one feel
like they can't afford it you know i'm
just i'm starting to get by i can't
afford having somebody on board
and to have tried bringing somebody on
board and it didn't work out so the god
I'm just gonna do it all myself and so
to address the first point the first
person I hired was for one hour day but
I mean I could afford one hour day I
couldn't afford full time but one hour
day the free app work that I sucked that
which is database work he was much
better at and freed me up to do the
things that I'm better at and so
eventually I could give that guy more
hours and then eventually hire somebody
full-time and build my way up but you
don't have to think I'm dropping this
much cash down because I need to be on
somebody full-time and then for the
second part of hiring and making a Mis
hire a guess and screwing up and feel
like god this this tire sucks i'm gonna
start over and do it all myself almost
everybody messes up their first hire
like you're not alone you don't know
what you're doing right like you think
you're just hiring for these skills and
you've never managed anybody before
you've never hired some before so the
chance is that just working out like
going down a hill on skis and expecting
to be awesome you know it's probably not
going to happen right you're probably
going to make some mistakes and fall
down and so that happens in the hiring
process to when you learn to get better
I think it's just making sure that the
first couple of Miss hires that you may
make don't sour you to the point where
you feel like I can't do anything I'm
going to do it all myself nobody can be
as good as me at all these things and
then a constant limits you because you
only have so much time in the day if you
want to build something important you
have to build a team so the question
that a today is what's your biggest fear
when it comes to hiring mmm i'll link
that question leave in the comments
below and we'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso okay
nespresso give me go